もう年超の場合等
バイトばっかりもうねほんとにね
マイターけどちょっとで
4万円落としたんで
元を取るという気持ちで頑張ってます
倍増最高
今日も探っと商品障害行く前
どりゃーだぞ
泥や土レアです
ドレア
このすごない
なら時間によって変わるんですよ食感があっ
そんで今までのアイスと大きく違うところはこれ二つ入ってるんですよ
何でも水カップルの方がいたらどれや
おすすめです yoko
いいだろう
アイス買ったんだ
剛ぞ
私も食べたいんだろう陽子俺は陽子のことを考えてすぐに計算済みだったのか
量も見てろこれ
どうだよ2つになったら食べさーん
って感じで2人でも食べれるっていう
場所なんです
あ中身はこんな感じです
モスラの卵60分だったらとても美味しいらしいです
白う
今食べる
ああなかなか濃厚ですね
抹茶メッツ強い
鳥あってお菓子まあ
アイスとしても食べれるしデザートとしても食べれるって言うな
水陸両用戦闘機みたいな感じです
何でも本当に美味しいですよあのぜひみなさん食べてみてください
60分までラインでちょっと
電子レンジで温めてきます
本当にこのませんで過去入ってるのねっ
ん
ドア
いい感じに溶けたを
もうやばいと月木さあ告げて来たーー
これは彼ますかねじぇねれーんになっちゃった
あーこれレンジのチェストも名はなんか
今日と同じがする
なんか舞妓さんが入っています何人かの舞妓はんがすごい
この中では阿波踊りをしているイメージがすごく強いですね
甘いものを過ぎの人ぜひ食べてみてください
じゃなく
思った